I was wondering when you would get
around to me bringing my oldest son
Xander to the dancing when it starts for
now the last night that you would try to
ask me if I would do it
I was waiting you waited to the top of
the third hour to do that are you gonna
do it well we're gonna put a pin in that
conversation we have Pam Oliver here on
[Music]
but Pam Oliver NFL on Fox Gracie Award
winner here on the Rich Eisen show the
43rd annual Gracie awards gala is
tonight here in Southern California and
you are a well deserved recipient of the
Gracie Award which we'll get to in a
second but Adam rip on one last night
I feel like I'm breaking news to a
reporter here but Josh Norman finished I
don't know if he finished a close second
over Tonya Harding
Josh Norman was fantastic great he was
fantastic I have into it like coming out
and that's the neat part about this not
to get too deep but when football
players take off the helmet and usually
when they have the helmet on and they
take off the helmet and you were
standing next to them they're angry or
they're emotional that's right right
yeah and then but to see he was just
chill last night and killing it he
crushed it I have a bond with Josh
Norman mm-hmm over a bracelet okay you
have the floor panel thank you we're in
a production meeting and he's giving us
all this information yeah it's just
locked in on this bracelet and it's this
cool leather strap kind of bracelet that
snapped and he's talking I'm looking at
the bracelet talking looking at the
bracelet and when it was over you know I
kind of said like I'm gonna say about
this and this can I have that I'm always
taking things off of people and he gave
me his leather snap bracelet okay and
you still I still have still half I rock
and every now and then okay yeah so my
version of the leather bracelets gonna
be that show coffee but not just the
coffee mug and the coaster we have who
took the coaster to the JK Simmons an
Academy Award again put her in his house
kitchen he didn't five-fingered that
thought finger discounted it why would
that baby as he was like I'm there's I'm
giving you one
when I leave this cup and this moisture
no you don't notice
Oh whack em sock em robot well that me
that do Rock'em Sock'em robot that we
have here I played with Oscar De La Hoya
owl and beat him I'm guessing again and
it stills frozen in the position of me
mocking his robot off that way forever
that's great best I can tell what does
winning this Gracie award mean to you
Pam what does that mean I think you know
I'm finally reaching a stage where I'm
just kind of accepting that you know
people feel like I blaze this trail or
that you know some people look up to me
and I've always been sort of resistant
to that a little bit because you know to
me I'm just Pam and I'm not just saying
that to try to be humble or anything
like that I've never really sought like
these accolades so I'm to a point now
where you know it's not gonna be much
longer how much longer I'm going to do
this so when someone takes the time to
you know nominate me and and for them to
decide to give me this award it does
mean a lot it's right up there with the
career highlight just because of the
other women that will also be honored
tonight it's not just news and sports
it's you know it's the entertainment
business radio I just feel like it's
gonna be a nice collection of women who
are kind of like-minded mm-hmm and when
people tell you about brazing blazing a
trail it's because you're an
african-american woman doing a sideline
job that nobody had really ever done
before so see on the at the NFL level
and you know which is at the time as
you're going about this you're not
thinking about well I am a black woman
doing this job you're like I'm a
reporter doing this job and how can I do
it to the best of my ability you know
you're gonna have ups and downs or you
know as a learning curve and all of that
but I think the thing that I was always
aware of is that I could not make the
same mistakes that say a man can make
they can misspeak on a name or someone
will just say oh he you know we didn't
get that right but if a woman did it
it's just like she does even know she's
talking about
I was very keenly aware of those types
of situations and you know I factored
that into just my drive I talked about
that with my wife all the time you know
being married to a sideline reporter
yeah that it is true and you say
something that's wrong you're clueless I
say something that's wrong I just
thought about misspoke I got it wrong
we were always given the men are always
given the benefit of the doubt has that
changed at all do you think I think a
little bit you don't do the reporter is
I think um well but then then I guess
maybe it has changed does it never used
to matter in that regard well yeah I
think people can kind of recognize who's
about the right thing and you know who's
who's dedicated to knowing as much about
what they're talking about as possible
and who's not Pam Oliver here on the
Rich Eisen show eight super bowls
correct you've lost track
god bless well that's good to be some no
it's not at all I'd love each and every
one no no
well you were there for the Brady ascent
yeah in the last Madden summer roll game
what was it like hands on the head
believe me wanna try what was it like
that week leading up it was the
obviously the Super Bowl that was
delayed a week because of 9/11 yeah you
too was playing halftime Brady and
Belichick had made a Super Bowl that few
thought that they could make the
greatest show on turf was in the
building Marshall Faulk I know it was a
great friend and colleague that was his
hometown yeah those last game exactly it
was they tend they tended to not add
extra pressure based on the bigness of
the event so it was like it always was
it was long days and lots of preparation
talking to a bunch of people just
getting your your stuff in order to be
prepared to you know do the biggest game
in the world that day you know I I took
I took a couple of pictures with Pat and
John but not many but those are the guys
I grew up with those were the guys when
we sat around in our living room my dad
my mom my two sisters and we'd watched
football
those were the voices
Summer Isles voice is unlike any other
but to be in the same room with those
guys III never took that for granted
right what was it like I guess for you
I'm just trying to figure out where you
you came straight from well you're the
SPN that's right yeah well I got there
just as you you left I guess you never
looked at the TV again after you laughs
never glanced up at the screen no notice
you on NFL on Fox for damn sure
that's what I just don't recall the
actual the actual time on that hat so
when you walk in and there's Matt and
there's summer on your first production
meetings I'm terrified you were I didn't
I didn't say a word
apparently I wasn't supposed to but yeah
it's just surprising reporters are you
know to be seen I mean to be yeah seen
and not heard but I that cuz I've had
lots of conversations again my wife yes
is very personal today for obvious
reasons yeah and that that cuz she would
you know when she was doing it she had
tons of storylines like she would spend
the week calling players moms and dads
I'm getting photographs from their
childhood and learning all of the
storylines 10 12 of them and then she'd
come home mostly that was left on the on
the base like that still I just so it's
just so happened yeah it's very
frustrating especially when you know
going in it's going to be a challenge to
even try to present these stories to get
them on the air i I still go through
that I call players I get these various
stories and then the game breaks out
sometimes it just doesn't work and you
know these stories that you've gathered
there's no place to put them but one
time I remember going in with seven
story ideas or things that you know I
could watch and see if I could add
something to them and not maybe one
story out of the seven but you still
have to try I mean you still want you
don't want to be the weakling you want
to try to add something that maybe these
guys don't know but yeah depending on
which group you're working with and how
open they are to even having you there
then you know that determines well I
also think that
sometimes we in our industry get lost in
the X's and O's and the whistles and the
bells and the the next generation stats
blah blah blah instead of storytelling
yeah
planning storytelling and you and a
sideline reporter you are not only being
able to flesh out some of these
storylines I want to know why I should
care about some of this stuff you know
some people might just have a betting
line that they're caring about but it's
also very important when something's
happening in the middle of the game
you're you are on the granite yeah
that's that's my job you're you're to be
I don't know how many cameras there are
twelve fifteen cameras that day but you
are to be an extra set of eyes and to do
that you need to know what to look for
and that's just from experience you know
you know when things aren't going well
you know they're somebody's getting gas
you know running the ball you you focus
on you know the defensive line and you
know how much effort they're spending
with that but you eventually learn the
ropes and you've you know you learn how
to kind of do it but it's the best place
to be and I've loved it and I continue
to love it and you know wouldn't give it
up for the world would you want to enjoy
it would you want to try something else
like play-by-play or something the place
never really appealed to me I know
people think that is probably the
end-all be-all or what's the next step
but I am happiest down on the sidelines
in the trenches kind of with the guys
and and that that level of just watching
the game right it makes me happy
who's the best coach you ever
interviewed worked with however like the
one that was got one you did for a
living and was helpful in that regard
um Tom Coughlin yep he was he was very
very supportive in that you know he
understood there were like when you walk
and talk with the coach at halftime he
would say things
I mean sometimes it was almost like a
filibuster I'm like you know I'm trying
to get a second question but he was one
of my all-time favorites for sure he was
funny too
I don't know people got his sense of
humor he he really just knew how to run
a football team maybe he was little
old-school in a lot of ways we tried to
you know meet the next generation where
they were and interesting some alternate
crowds old-school guys might be like why
do I need to ask answer to questions as
I'm running off the field at halftime I
got to go in there and prepare so that's
interesting he would some of these
coaches run Tom would just walk saunter
and you know dance my question and Tom
mcveigh's a runner Shaun McVeigh's a
runner as well so he's a runner because
he's 31 for credit yeah and I'm thinking
well maybe he'll make an exception since
I'm 110 yeah yeah okay so so you know I
had on impractical shoes that day so
just like shod give me a break
I have lived this I remember Suzy when
she's she's packing she's got like this
trip I would never think I'm just a
screw it I'll just wear some shoes but
you're walking around all day in a field
he's gonna rain is it not yeah it's
that's so funny and it's great that you
have that perspective I have a few gosh
do I have it you know and it let's be
honest though Coughlin likes you because
you showed up five minutes early to for
the meeting that's where you're getting
it so before by the way okay yeah I
heard you earlier with you know perch
talking on high from about how these
players should just be you know so
grateful to be invited to the White
House it is a special place okay
and I'm not trying to come at you or
anything I'm just letting you know I too
have been to the White House okay well I
mean I didn't I didn't seem to got him
come across like it was on a perch yeah
you're kind of hanging your horse I was
yeah yeah I didn't come across to say
that I've been there the only one there
but well I was watching in your green
room as a viewer I felt you were high on
your horse well what do you think of the
Eagles being invited then I'll give you
the floor um I think that's
to have been expected and it be
interesting to see who goes and who does
that
okay but I don't think you know there's
not a requirement for you to go
obviously but right that's what I said
to you were like if you invited what he
got out of the White House no I said
that normally I have taken that approach
but this time if you're called a son of
a [ __ ] I understand if you don't want
to go mhm yeah which is what I said oh
maybe I would miss that last maybe I was
listening to like little Wayne at that
point I'm starting to get myself fired
up to come out here no I'm like it's I
completely hurt but you said okay yeah
you don't feel you were I don't think a
horse I wanted to explain that I have
been there before and it is certainly
knowing I'll be honest with you if we're
gonna get into it here well certainly
knowing that so many people view
everything so politically I want to make
sure that I'm in viewing my comments is
that I've not only been at the White
House I was there at a GOP president so
I'm not coming at it from some sort look
at you smiling at me right now you guys
think I mean I think he's full up what's
the name of the show no do you have any
do you have any advice that you want to
give to folks who want to follow in your
footsteps
before you go yeah and it's it's really
simple you know just respect the process
journalism is a craft and just be true
to that and I think all that other stuff
will fall away if you're committed and
you love it and you're passionate about
it you're all set well Congrats on when
you're worried I appreciate that take
the mug there you go you've got yourself
I will do whatever it sure oh do you
need that one is that no that's uh no
I've already done that good to see you
Pamela so good to be here thank you so
much I really really really respect you
thank you I appreciate you spike you're
high on your horse position I don't
think you're high on your horse no he
was saying look normally I would take
this stance where if you're invited you
go but in this case I don't wanna come
across as hypocritical yeah you know I
mean normally I've
in the past if you're invited you should
go because you're invited you're
respecting the office in the country and
cetera but if the person who's occupying
that has called you a son-of-a-bitch I
understand if you don't want to go all
right I love you too all right the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience